when it's against when we do it
but it's not okay when other people do
it against
us but they read from the quran and they
suddenly have the right way
and the actual saying of theirs it makes
no difference
and then you wonder why your children
are coming up with all of these doubts
how could one being really be the one to
tell a spoken word
something we don't want to have our
children
just being muslims by natan or by name
we want because everyone at one point in
their life they have to make a conscious
decision
[Applause]
the question here is how can i help
guide a person
who was brought up muslim and due to a
personality
leaning towards other religions or
atheism and the other one will tackle
both these at the same time how
should i go about giving dawah to a
person who is aggressively
passionate it's underlying here
aggressively passionate
of their atheist beliefs i personally
don't believe
that there is anything even though the
term is used atheist that there's no
such thing as
an atheist i believe there's a person
who's confused
the root of the matter is that there is
an institution set up
from the high schools from the
elementary schools to the high schools
and even deeper
in the colleges where you have
a secular atheist system set up
to give you dollar to get you
out of your dean
so when you go into this ocean not well
equipped
and then you wonder why your children
are coming up with all of these doubts
and then when you go to the colleges you
go to the frat parties
it's a vacation from home
so then what happens a mask gets put on
and when i talk to a lot of these people
who claim to be atheists
when you dig a little deeper they don't
know what the hell they're talking about
excuse me they just want to
follow their lust passions and desires
and the conscious they want to turn it
off
because it's eating them away so i'm
just gonna deny god
there's a great documentary called
expelled
write this down i want everybody to
watch it
no intelligence allowed
it's done by some academics some
christians
and it shows that anyone who argues
for creationism for there being a
creator from the academic acute
community it shows the mafia style
[Music]
gang mentality of the academics
who gang up on these individuals so now
you don't want to
get blacklisted you don't want to
get excluded from the social events
so many people are not courageous enough
to come out so they shut these people
down
i told you as the system is set up
to take you away from your deen if
you're not well equipped
equipped then you're going to fall so
when i talk to someone going to the
question
and when i talk about most people don't
know what they're talking about because
when they quote people like the richard
dawkins and many of
the other prophets of atheism
the words they use the things they say
have their books they haven't read
and they're using terms they don't
understand they're confused
so you go with them and you fall in a
pit of confusion and this is
shaytan's trap so just because your head
is spinning and they're just
giving empty rhetoric it doesn't make
any sense we go to what makes
sense the dean makes sense and sometimes
it making so much sense confuses you
because you're listening to the
professor and half the stuff you don't
understand
you're like wow he's so smart but how
could this be so simple
it's easy to understand it's basic 101
because the message is for everyone not
just for the academic
but the person when he goes the better
one when he goes to the desert
and he sees the dung or he's the he sees
the footsteps
of the camel he says
this is the camel everything out this is
from the camel but the signs that i see
around me
the sun the moon the deserts these are
the signs that there is an almighty
creator allah
ibn tamiya one of the great scholars
said
how can you you asking for the the
evidence the one who's asking for the
evidence of the existence of allah how
can you show them when the whole
creation is screaming his existence
so we go back to finishing this question
we go back to what makes sense
you have a few solid key
points not confusing
that anybody can go ahead and because a
lot of the arguments go back
into these cosmological arguments that
everything that became
into existence must have a cause
the universe came into existence it has
to have a cause
nothing comes from nothing so
in order for something to come into
exist has to have a cause common sense
are you with me makes sense let me hear
you
let me go through these real quickly
second point
intelligent design no fine tuning the
fine
tuning of the universe isaac newton
made the example of the solar system
[Music]
relating it to a fine tuning of a clock
now who would think
any watchmakers here nobody
have you ever seen the
details of what goes into a fine-tuned
watch anybody
would you think that came by accident
fine-tuning of the universe
how everything is sent for the
components that we need
to live on this earth everything is set
that a lecture can be given just on that
then we have arguments by design
some of the great colder fires they call
them of logic
socrates plato these are like the
intellectuals that everybody points to
and all of these
atheists so the argument
by design you wouldn't think if you just
went by
and dr seville gives a beautiful example
but if you go
and you find a watch again on the shore
of an
ocean by the beach you again you
wouldn't think that this just designed
itself it was an accident
and then the moral argument good and bad
where does it come from
if there's no creator you got people in
germany
and in denmark they are
fighting for their right to have sex
with animals so you see
for the one who allah elevates him the
creator elevates him to a
high status but the person the human
being brings himself to such a low level
so i will bring the person back to some
of these basic points
and then we'll bring them back to the
omg the oneness of allah
the messenger ship the guidance that was
sent
the hereafter and then the miracles i
just did a program of the prophecies
of the quran too many to list the
evidences are beyond and beyond
so if a person is sincere and humble
then allah will guide him but it's on
our duty just to share these facts
and then don't worry about it leave it
to allah be the best example you can be
know your deen and make sure you're
sharing this message with clarity
and though when you make it clear it
stands out
from everything else
[Applause]
extremism and terrorism these are acts
they can be done by a person of islamic
faith christian faith or no faith
islam do not have a monopoly on it
important so i mentioned to them that
there are 406
thousand not 100 406
000 deaths by gun violence every single
act is an
act of terrorism important
then we also mentioned what happened in
new zealand that guy who killed
49 people it's an act of terrorism by a
christian terrorist
in norway andre bravic 78 people were
gunned down
by a person who identified himself as a
christian
so what i say to them is every single
one of them is an act of terrorism
and point number two is that if you
agree i say this to my non-muslim
friends and colleagues in the open
houses
i say to them raise your hand if you say
and if you believe that every life is
equal in the eyes of god
life of a muslim a christian a jew an
atheist every life is equal
they all have to raise their hand they
cannot deny that allah says
translation do not go to extreme because
allah does not love the extremists
really important so what are the
guidelines the etiquettes of a just war
allah says or the prophet mentioned in
one of his battles he saw a woman dead
he was not happy he called his
companions
and he told them that even in a war do
not kill women and children
that means no non-combatant should be
touched harmed or killed
that's how careful is islam in a just
war this one is is
addressed to you sheikh who says sheikh
rhythm so they took your title put on me
i'm just getting old here
that's you you're associated it says
what
if someone asks you that if you die
tomorrow
and you end up being in jahannam the
hellfire
and the god you the god you were
claiming to
and the god you were worshiping to is
non-existence how would you
respond to them well first that if
you you're not going to end up in the
hellfire or anywhere if there's no god
according to to them the second i would
flip the question and i would say
but if there is which we know there is a
creator
god almighty allah then what are you
going to do
and it's just a real quick example of
let's say you're heading down the
freeway
and a good friend of your trustworthy
friend he's never lied to you
he's always told the truth he don't even
play jokes when he lies he's telling you
look get off here
at this exit because there's a six seven
hour traffic jam coming up ahead
it's a trustworthy person you're gonna
ignore this front of yours just get off
we're gonna be stuck take a chance being
stuck now
in the seven hour traffic jam small
example but something
greater is all these messengers
they weren't liars they really existed
abraham ibrahim alayhi salam moses noah
jesus in the last the final message of
muhammad they're all saying the same
thing no two philosophers can get it
right they all have different opinions
but they're all coming and communicating
the same question
worship the one god alone be morally
upright
and prepare for what comes next and then
what
and where did you go wrong you got a
believable message based on proof and
evidence
that's helping you to become a better
human being
a whole road map to personal development
everything that allah told us to do is
good from us from the salah you got the
tony robbins of the world
you got the oprah winfries all talking
about meditation in the morning
20 30 minutes closing your eyes
reflecting being grateful
is that not salah from the movements
that we benefit from
they can tell you in the yoga benefits
we're not doing it for yoga or any of
that but we get the
best from grounding i didn't talk on
grounding
when you get your head to the ground we
do it for the spiritual benefits but
we're getting all the sort of
physical the emf rays that are that the
distress from the body
subhanallah benefit upon benefit you do
it to collect
to be grateful show gratefulness to your
lord the things that he told us to stay
away from
we don't need who the health
organization to tell us that every
10 seconds someone is dying from alcohol
allah
loves us and he told us to stay away
from it the pork
just go ahead and read all of the
disasters from the health that will
happen
the tapeworms that you get in your brain
amazing
subhanallah fasting right now it's a
huge trend
intermittent fasting 18 hours this is
amazing
so everything look gambling is the
second growing fastest addiction breaks
up homes
and the list goes on porn number one
addiction
so everything that allah told us to do
it's for us he don't need it
it benefits us we don't need the tony
robbins and all the other
motivational speakers yeah maybe we can
get some good stuff here and there but
it's all in the deen
so when you practice the dean you get
the best of both worlds
because you benefit with it in this life
but then you got the
ultimate reward in jannah inshallah
for us to talk about atheists but if
they wrote what they think
and i read what they think and i present
them right i think it's equal
same thing if the people will represent
islam without the presence of any muslim
but they read from the quran and the
sunnah the right way and the actual
saying of theirs it makes no difference
any time
and we always make that clear you're
dealing with any human being
you deal with them because the prophet
saw said i have not been sent except to
perfect good manners
so when you deal with people you're in
the downfield
with any human being no matter what
eight he is christian you deal with him
compassion mercy and love
but the ideas that people come with
we talk about someone's confused someone
is out of the love that we go ahead and
we're trying to
reason and talk with people so it's
those ideas that we challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
i used to
look at me i'm so strong i can choose
what i want to do i can choose any job
i can breathe when i want to breathe but
then i heard my heart beats and my
subconscious makes it think three times
before i can really think what to do
right
i got on my knees i put my hands on the
floor i said y'all love please i'm
trying to seek in my love
made a lot of money so i thought i was
good the pride and greed made me hungry
until
allah said no you're not ready for it i
was wondering
it does not feel like man you're eating
my hunger is still rumbling
understand man the whole prophecy
the bubble is so easy so sensitive the
human
indemnity that's our love is the
insurance
we still don't understand that we look
up to the stars but you know human
revolution made it so
hard to see the skies that's allah
thank you so much for letting me show
you these words see
we don't we don't need eminem for 50
cents and we don't need all the beats
man
you got the spoken
cover a lot of ground a lot of exciting
topics you don't want to miss out you
want to be here every friday and then
we'll try to give you some short
reminders in between
but you can't get that if you're not
coming back to the show
every week fridays we'll be releasing it
god willing inshallah
subscribe right now and enjoy all of the
content that we're going to be putting
out
for you thank you peace be with you
assalamu